[Musica]
alzi la mano chi di voi magari dopo una
giornata particolarmente lunga e
faticosa sente la necessità di infilare
un cucchiaio in un barattolo di
cioccolata o magari di sentire una
canzone vedo già tante mani alzate anche
io l'alzo o magari di sentire una bella
canzone come quelle che abbiamo
ascoltato sino ad ora solo una biologa
quindi mi interrogo ok ma quali sono i
motivi che mi fanno sentire questo
piacere nel compiere entrambe le azioni
sia mangiare cioccolata che ascoltare
buona musica
il perché le nostre cellule producono un
ormone un neurotrasmettitore che ai più
è noto come ormone della felicità
si chiama serotonina è stato scoperto
parecchi anni fa dall'università da un
giovane neo laureato della mia
università all'università di pavia e mai
identificata nelle cellule epiteliali
della mucosa gastrica dell'intestino
all'inizio veniva chiamata come intera
mina successivamente noi la conosciamo
come serotonina è un ormone è anche un
neurotrasmettitore per intenderci è
quello che regola il ciclo di sonno
veglia di fame sazietà favorisce
l'apprendimento anche se il suo ruolo il
ruolo per il quale meglio conosciuta
sicuramente è l'influenza che ha sul
nostro umore quindi una situazione
particolarmente piacevole io lo associa
appunto al cioccolato fa scattare il
precursore della serotonina che è un
aminoacido si chiama triptofano dal
sangue al cervello dove attraverso
diversi passaggi viene convertita in
serotonina e gli effetti sono quelli che
conosciamo tutti quindi sempre parlando
di cioccolato avete capito che mi piace
particolarmente
quando scartiamo un cioccolatino ci sono
all'incirca 200 300 composti del
cioccolato che stimolano il nostro
cervello a rilasciare delle sostanze
particolarmente piacevoli una di questa
è la dopamina
certo
dovremmo mangiarne in quantità per
ottenere un effetto così evidente
diciamo che una persona intorno ai 100
kg dovrebbe mangiare più o meno 20 kg di
cioccolato
ora assorbe ho sentito il brusio e
quindi immagino che state mentalmente
calcolando perché l'ho fatto anche io le
quantità di cioccolato che potreste
sentirvi autorizzati a mangiare in base
al vostro peso corporeo
magari i numeri potrebbero risultare un
pochino alti non ci spaventiamo ma
pensiamo insomma che normali quantità
sono possono essere comunque assai
appaganti e diciamo che la stessa cosa
accade più o meno quando riceviamo
dell'affetto un bacio e un abbraccio di
cui in realtà dovremmo e potremmo
riceverne in abbondanza ora vi chiedo
uno sforzo di farvi piccolini di entrare
all'interno del vostro corpo ed
immaginare cosa producono le cellule
invece in una situazione opposta ovvero
quando siamo magari christie siamo
depressi non ci sentiamo amati ebbene le
cellule producono un altro ormone che è
conosciuto come ormone dello stress o
cortisolo un ormone steroideo e deriva
da ben più noto è assai temuto
soprattutto dopo gli esami del sangue
colesterolo è normale ovvio pensare
anche che normali livelli di stress sono
utili perché sono quelli che ci
permettono di superare delle situazioni
particolarmente importanti quali possono
essere un colloquio di lavoro un compito
in classe o un'interrogazione o seminari
in pubblico ma è chiaro che alti livelli
di stress non fanno bene alle nostre
cellule al dna perché questo vuol dire
che molto cortisolo viene prodotto e
questo può avere un impatto negativo non
solo a livello del sistema nervoso
centrale ma anche a livello del sistema
immunitario e ad esempio di quello
cardiovascolare per cui magari un giorno
in cui non ci sentiamo proprio felici se
qualcuno ci dice dai magari dandoci una
pacca sulla spalla ridi che ti passa
ecco non mandiamo la colpa non trattiamo
lo male perché la risata ha in effetti
un potere molto bello perché oltre a da
passà ad abbassare i livelli di
cortisolo abbassa anche il senso di
paura e permette il rilascio di
endorfine che sono quelle sostanze che
hanno questa capacità ansiolitica e
antidolorifica pensate che c'è anche un
antichissimo proverbio nepalese che dice
che se ridi più di dieci volte al giorno
ogni giorno la tua vita si allungherà è
un bel messaggio
a mio avviso certo dobbiamo essere
fortunati e circondarsi di persone anche
che ci permettono di ridere così tante
volte al giorno quindi insomma mi
sentirei di seguirlo questo consiglio le
situazioni che ho appena elencato sono
quelle che ci troviamo a vivere più o
meno costantemente tutti quanti noi
perché passiamo da momenti di gioia a
momenti di una tristezza cosmica e
incredibile magari anche per le cose più
futili però vi chiede un altro sforzo
ora non di farvi più di farvi piccoli
piccoli e di guardarvi da dentro ma di
uscire dalla vostra area di conforto da
quella in cui ci troviamo
grazie alla fortuna che abbiamo avuto di
nascere nella parte ricca e agiata del
pianeta e proviamo invece a pensare a
che cosa succede alle cellule al dna
di chi è stato meno fortunato di noi di
chi magari non ha un tetto sotto cui
dormire di chi vive con poche monete in
tasca o magari di chi durante tutta la
sua vita ha dovuto subire delle violenze
fisiche e mentali anche inimmaginabili
di chi insomma non ha avuto i mezzi e la
fortuna di prendersi adeguatamente cura
di se stesso e degli altri
il contesto sociale nel quale si
sviluppa il ciclo vitale degli individui
è in grado di influenzare molti processi
biologici
so che sembrano degli e paroloni ma ha
detto in parole povere appunto è come la
vita quotidiana può influenzare il
nostro dna
le nostre azioni le nostre emozioni
quotidiane e questo concetto era stato
pensato in tempi antichi nel 1848 da un
politologo patologo tedesco il cui nome
era rudolf birkhoff lui aveva studiato
questa relazione tra la condizione
sociale e le malattie ed era arrivato
alla giustissima conclusione che l'unico
modo l'unica vera cura per determinati
tipi di patologie per in generale in
realtà tutte le patologie proprio quello
di garantire libertà istruzione è una
certa sicurezza economica a tutti quanti
e penso che lui avesse ragione penso che
forse sono i tre ingredienti che
dovremmo tenere a mente anche per
superare questo momento un po difficile
che stiamo vivendo tutti quanti noi
ho appena menzionato il contesto sociale
il contesto sociale il quale si sviluppa
il ciclo vitale degli individui non
parlo più di contesto sociale ora ma mi
focalizzo da biologa al ciclo vitale al
nostro ciclo vitale e quindi dal suo
punto di partenza dalla formazione di
due celluline che sono quelle che io
studio in laboratorio sono le cellule
germinali cellule uovo e spermatozoi
sono cellule intrigantissima che dalla
fusione dei due
nuclei formano l'embrione noi il feto il
giovane adulto il senescente e durante
tutte queste fasi quindi sia la quando
siamo embrioni cini a quando siamo
adulti in grado di rimanere sulle nostre
gambe oltre cellule tessuti e organi
sono disposti a diversi ambienti e il
termine ambiente
qui va considerato nella sua più ampia
accezione per le cellule uovo lo
spermatozoo sono ambiente sono le varie
il testicolo per l'embrione il feto
l'organismo materno per il giovane
adulto il senescente l'aria l'acqua la
scuola le interazioni sociali la vita
quotidiana ad esempio che vi ho fatto
prima
quindi mi viene da farvi un'altra
domanda
lo so è banale perdonatemi ma secondo
voi quanto è importante prenderci cura
di questi diversi ambienti
ovviamente tanto come appunto è
facilmente intuibile
questo perché durante le diverse fasi
cellule dna sono esposte ad una serie di
agenti chimici e fisici pensate agli
inquinanti
pensate alle micro e allenano plastiche
che purtroppo sono ormai nell'acqua
nell'aria nel cibo ma anche condizioni
sociali stati emotivi che sebbene non
alterino la sequenza del dna la doppia
elica quella che sicuramente tutti
quanti abbiamo in mente ne modificano
l'espressione dei geni e questo può
comportare l'insorgenza di diverse
patologie
e la cosa ancora più inquietante è che
questo può essere trasmesso da una
generazione a quella successiva
quindi il contesto sociale nel quale
nasciamo può conferire dei vantaggi e
degli svantaggi e alcuni economisti in
tempi molto recenti addirittura dicevano
che il nostro indirizzo il nostro codice
di avviamento postale è quello che sarà
in grado di dire e di predire come sarà
la nostra vita in futuro
il ramo della biologia che studia tutte
queste interazioni a livello dei geni ma
senza la modifica della sequenza del dna
è quella che prende il nome di
epigenetica è un campo affascinantissimo
epigenetica e ciò che sta sopra alla
genetica
ebbene immaginiamo per rendere magari
per visualizzare meglio questo aspetto
il nostro genoma come una libreria in
cui diversi libri sono i geni e ora
cercate di visualizzare all'interno di
questa libreria quindi il nostro dna
alcuni libri quindi alcuni geni che sul
dorso presentano delle etichette di
quelle che si possono attaccare e
staccare
ebbene quei libri quei geni con le
etichette sono quelli che noi possiamo
leggere ma tradotto nella biologia sono
i geni che a seconda delle condizioni
della nostra vita quotidiana possono
essere espressi oppure no se prendiamo
un libro dalla libreria quindi un gene
si esprime così silenzio la struttura
della libreria del nostro dna del nostro
genoma non cambia ma le informazioni che
noi riceviamo grazie alla lettura del
libro grazie all'accensione o allo
spegnimento del gene sono diverse prima
ha citato il cortisolo e di quanto possa
essere dannoso se prodotto in risposta a
situazioni particolari
tutti noi viviamo in un contesto di
interdipendenza con altri individui per
cui oggi più che mai va ribadito con una
voce squillante che avere cura
dell'altro praticare la cultura del dono
essere generosi a un ritorno per tutti
quanti le ineguaglianze sono quelle che
accrescono i conflitti ed era già la
biologia evolutiva che ci diceva che
sono le strategie di reciprocità e di
generosità ad essere quelle vincenti ed
era un campo che aveva affascinato
tantissimo anche
come in un biologi chiamiamo che sarebbe
charles darwin ei suoi colleghi biologi
ovvero che rimanevano incantati proprio
da questa capacità che ha la natura di
essere di mostrare comportamenti
generosi e soprattutto altruistici e se
pensiamo per il nostro corpo sicuramente
questo non può che avere effetti
positivi grazie alla produzione di
serotonina e dopamina di cui abbiamo
parlato prima
spesso si paragona il si paragonano sia
il corpo che il cervello ad un giardino
per cui il giardino che deve essere
innaffiato e curare e curare in un bel
modo per cui risulta doverosa citazione
a william shakespeare che diceva che il
nostro corpo e proprio con un giardino
di cui giardiniere la nostra volontà
quindi cerchiamo di prendersene davvero
cura e di creare meraviglie e citando
una grande donna che raffredda calo
innamoriamoci di noi stessi della vita e
dopo di chi vogliamo
e io mi permetto di aggiungere lasciamo
però che siano la serotonina la dopamina
ad essere le note musicali che cullano
cellule e dna che sono dirette dal
miglior direttore d'orchestra di cui noi
sapiens sapiens siamo dotati che alla
cultura quella intesa con la c maiuscola
quella intesa come empatia capacità di
condividere e di prenderci cura di noi e
di chi ci sta attorno
grazie